let's go back to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 with our caller from the 7:03
area code he's calling today from 7 0 3
wait on me yes it is with me hi I'm
Amelia I've been watching your show for
a while I'm 16 years old and I'm just
wondering if you think that the current
media card is really loud in here as
long as you think that the way that
politics are done these days with some
more like personal attacks and more
glamour and showmanship if that makes
young people like more apathetic or more
more apathetic or more like passionate
about sorry it's really loud
if you think that I wonder if you face
that modern politics is like damaging to
young people are like makes them more
interested in passionate and you want to
fix things I don't I would actually need
to hear from you about that I mean when
I see the way that politics has been
turned into a reality show we have a
reality show president their last State
of the Union was essentially a reality
show event with you know secret guests
coming out unannounced and medals and
prizes and all sorts of stuff I find it
absolutely disgusting and despicable but
I mean you tell me Emilia if you're 16
are you finding that you are drawn in by
this sort of reality show politics or do
you find it distasteful I think that it
makes kids my age please either
apathetic or more passionate I think
they're you because I think kids younger
than me might see this and start
thinking of politics as like a game I
certainly know some of my classmates do
but it just kind of makes me disgusted
and I want better because I wasn't
politically it like didn't know anything
because during the entire Obama
administration he got elected when I was
like I don't know five right though yeah
and I didn't know anything about bush
or so me coming into becoming aware of
the world and the becoming aware of the
world and aware of politics and policies
and then learning history as well same
time it kind of makes it seem like it
all always been this way it is all right
now know that it's hard to understand
that you know because we in our lifetime
we only observe a certain number of
political cycles and it can be very easy
to feel like the way things are the way
that it's always been I mean I can even
tell you just in the elections that I've
observed like when I was in high school
george w bush was elected for the first
time things are very different now than
they were in some senses they are the
same but in some senses they're very
very different listen it's great that
you're politically engaged it sounds
crazy where you are amelia so i'm gonna
let you go all right but i hope you'll
call back yeah okay thank you
all right good thank you so much great
to hear from amelia just very very loud
wherever she was